help me get this thing off I'm sorry
Monti and rose Congrats on the film I
wanted to break down the spaghetti scene
with you guys how did you guys pull that
off wow that must have taken a lot of
coordination was it awkward having to
kiss your co-star how much of the
spaghetti did you guys have to eat
that's a lot of gluten what was it like
working with Justin and Tessa oh that's
really sweet
Congrats on the film I can't wait for
everyone to see it thank you guys for
sitting with me what is this place
there's a great big world out there
with no fence around it congratulations
on the film I loved it I cried it's so
good I can't wait for people to see this
what was it like having such incredible
performers portray you guys are you
asking them it was the best like it was
every day and again it's a thing we
started recording before they started
shooting so as our recording sessions
women on we started getting delivered
footage and cut scenes of them and it
was just really cool like just to see
you know see it start to take shape
take life and some of the digital
animation started to come in it just
became incredible you've brought up such
an acute interesting point that we as
humans like to sort of imagine the
voices of dogs anyways imagine their
inner life and give them and give them
voice so it was you know just a joy to
get to do that over this past year I'm
and to get to do it with I mean really
they're such incredible performers and
they look lonely to do all this stuff
fresh they didn't go to any fancy acting
school they were discovered what a fun
film to be a part of it's such a classic
um was there anything from the animated
film that you were happy to see returned
in this movie I mean you got if you've
lady in the [ __ ] you've got to have the
spaghetti scene you're not gonna not put
that dick no we cut that for time yeah
it's like that's gotta be dog-eat-dog
business dog eats spaghetti I gotta go
yeah like it wasn't changed in macaroni
or anything yeah that seems was there
anything you guys were excited that was
new yeah I was excited in in in the
original film she's muzzled for a while
so you don't get to hear her voice and
one of the first things that Charlie
being the director said to me is we want
to get her speaking sooner wait
I think it's great because why wouldn't
you want to hear I think we were able to
capture that you know the muzzle but
still have her have a voice in a
presence which i think is great yeah and
I love that we learned more of Trance
backstory to in this movie and nothing
um Tessa this movie premieres on Disney
Plus so I have to ask would you like to
see Valkyrie get her own show and if so
what story would you like to see her
explore that's so cool I hadn't even
thought about that honestly I'm so
excited about all of the Marvel shows
that will happen on Disney plus I think
all of them are incredible and and
really excited about the Loki show for
example no you know I just love playing
the character and I love I I'm really
excited about love and thunder we get to
shoot this coming year and Natalie
Portman is taking up the hammer and I'm
so excited to have her returned to the
series and to get to work with her you
know I love the idea of in the next
phase getting to see all of the
incredible you know people that are sort
of newer to the MCU get to play more
together and love spending time with you
know people like brie and deny so it
would be great to get to team up with
them in any way whether it's on Disney
Plus on a show or on the big screen or
just over plate of spaghetti
you